I've read every book in the Omaha Public
Library that was on by the time I was 12
the fastest way to win is to model
success to people I always would read
about and we're Thomas Edison and Walt
Disney rise and shine it's an spresso
time good morning belief nation it's
Evan my one word is believed and I
believe in you I believe you have an
amazing gift inside you that I want to
see exploded onto the world so grab your
coffee and sip on today's message model
success over to you Warren Buffett who
was Ben Graham he was your primary
mentor model it was a wonderful man and
he was my professor at Columbia I read
his book when I was 19 at the University
of Nebraska and I'd started investing
when I was 11 I started reading about it
when I was like seven so I'd gone
through all I read every book in the
Omaha Public Library that was on by the
time I was 12 on investing in stock
market and I had a lot of fun but I
never really found out I never got
grounded to anything and it was it was
entertaining but it wasn't gonna be
profitable and then I read Graham's book
the Intelligent Investor when I was at
the university of braska and pulled over
the whole thing up to me yeah and I and
I named my my oldest son is named Howard
after my dad Graham Buffett and then he
was a marvelous man I never expected
anything from me in return he just did
all these things for younger people the
fastest way to wane is the model success
whatever problem is in front of you
whatever challenge is right in front of
your face whatever obstacle you need to
overcome know this somebody has already
solved it the fastest way for you to
shortcut your path is to learn from the
people who've solved that challenge
understand what they did to solve it and
apply it to your current situation if
there is any shortcut to success that I
know of this is it model success too
many people are constantly stuck in
their own head that they need to figure
out the answer to every single problem
and this is what I almost sunk my first
business I thought I had to come up with
every single answer and the aha moment
was realizing I'm not the first guy to
try to sell software before somebody has
figured this out by modeling the success
maybe I can get beyond making $300 a
month and not able to survive right and
modeling Bill Gates is the thing that
saved my company now if you are
subscribed to this channel you by now
understand the value of model and
success and your appreciating all the
content that we'll put now learning from
all these different people what I would
encourage you is try to learn from
people who you don't immediately
resonate with I think this is so
important I think people are so locked
into certain schemas they're so locked
into a certain way of learning that you
only want to learn from one kind of
person you only want to learn from
person who looks like this who's done
this and are in this special box those
are the only people you want to learn
from or if you can expand that and learn
from anybody who's had success that's
where you can really grow when you can
learn to model the successes of people
who you hate you don't immediately
resonate with but there's one thing that
they did even if you disagree with 99
percent of their actions there's one
thing that they did that was genius that
you can apply to your life being able to
learn from that person really will make
you extraordinary and so I look at Steve
Jobs as an example you know he's a great
visionary entrepreneur I love the big
mission he has I love the desire to want
to make an impact and dent in the
universe so I can model that from him
but I'm not gonna model his fatherhood
you know I don't want to be a father
like he was a father and that's okay I
look at someone like Kanye West and a
lot of people hate on Kanye West Kanye
West is a genius entrepreneur he's done
a lot of amazing things that you can
learn from to make your business better
even if you don't want to have the
paparazzi lifestyle even if you don't
like how he interrupted Taylor Swift on
live TV even if he puts you know his
foot in his mouth sometimes you don't
have to take that part but if you write
people off because they've done a few
bad things and you're unwilling to learn
from them by putting them in that box
you're putting yourself in a box you're
restricting yourself of who you can
learn from how much knowledge you can
acquire and how far
gonna go so a challenge that I have for
you guys today is look through this
channel and find somebody who you look
at their face you say I hate that person
and go try to learn something from them
it'll shift your perspective it'll make
you a way better person and entrepreneur
now I've got some special bonus clips
for you but before that my question of
the day is I want to know who have you
learned the most from on this channel
who's been your biggest mentor and why
leave it on the comments below I'm
really curious to find out thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love enjoy the bonus clips and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of an espresso
[Music]
had some family role models and I had
some other people you know some sort of
historical role models that I looked at
too so certainly my my grandfather was a
serious role model for me I just did fit
so much time I you learn different
things from grandparents and you learn
from parents it's a it's a great I would
encourage anybody to try to spend time
not only with their parents but with
their grandparents and but I and I also
had I to people I always would read
about and we're Thomas Edison and Walt
Disney those were sort of my - you know
biographical heroes I always been
interested in in inventors and invention
and Edison of course just you know for
for a little kid is the and probably for
adults too I still feel this way at
least is that not only the symbol of
that but the actual fact of that they
just incredible inventor and and I've
always felt that there's a certain kind
of important pioneering that goes on
from an inventor like Thomas Edison and
then Disney was a different sort of
thing
he also you know a real pioneer and an
inventor and doing new things but it
seemed to me that he had this incredible
capability to create a vision that he
could get a large number of people to
share because the the things that Disney
invented like Disneyland you know the
theme parks are so and they were such
big visions that no single individual
unlike a lot of the things that Edison
worked on no single individual could
ever pull them off and and Walt Disney
really was able to get a big team of
people working in a concerted direction
when you got started who who were you
modeling yourself after who who were the
the people that that you're like I I
want that there's like there's like
three three stages of it there's like
there's like when before I was an actor
when I started going to movies there
were three it was like movies of Robert
De Niro movies of Eddie Murphy
of Richard Gere Wow so those would like
the guys that I kind of like look you
know before I started acting and I was
already going to the movies on my own
paying it and then after when I started
acting then it was like you know then it
was Pacino
you know Marlon Brando then I started
discovering Humphrey Bogart and what
actors you know Anthony Quinn a lot of
actors that are not around anymore
they still moved me you know I I can
watch you know a good Anthony Quinn
movie or or or or a Brando movie you
know it's just like I just I just can't
watch it now and black one doesn't bug
me but that's you know and then there
were other young actors that were doing
stuff that really kind of like were a
bit more contemporary like Sean Penn
Gary Oldman they were doing this like
they were going out there and taking
chances and that's when I started acting
that's what like oh those were like
actors that I kind of like how come I
want to mold it ya know you know you
know like that or like like their
pattern one of us knew the business true
and we and with Emily we knew so little
about the variety store business that we
had to take the book that was written by
Ben Franklin and apply the principles
and apply the controls the and the
merchandise merchandising programs that
the outline for us but of course knowing
you and knowing I myself a little bit we
added on didn't we
that's that's exactly right but we were
Mavericks even then and we were started
doing strange things like cranking up
ice cream machines on the sidewalk on
Saturday night popping popcorn on the
other end of the sidewalk honking
anything we get Hulk off that looked
like it might have a chance to sell
wherever it made an easy life actually
we worked hard that's right but but it
gave us a vehicle to to ride on that's
right exactly
without without having to buy
merchandise you know ourselves all the
time or distribution centers
not having to do the thing we'd have to
do when we built Walmart would see Mars
lowers volume you yeah the most
important work ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you Apple that would be
like a little beacon hey believe nation
if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details